we're dealing with series we're dealing
with limited series or what I used to
call miniseries feature-length projects
half our projects short form projects
animation live events sports news we
cross all genres and the bottom line is
is that we're exactly where you can find
it is through xbox live now we're still
trying to figure out from a strategic
standpoint where it sits but it's
something that's really unique to our
platform and it will be under the banner
of xbox originals should we think about
these shows being produced start to
finish by Microsoft or buy xbox or is it
in partnership with other studios well
we're open to all in fact we have a an
arrangement with channel 4 in the UK
that we're producing a series together
we can co-produce will solely produce we
will we will bring in talent so we're
very very flexible with whom we will
work with well let's use showtimes as an
example I mean traditionally TV you
think 30 minutes you think an hour even
in some of the new platforms shows that
are done for platforms like Netflix
you're still kind of thinking in those
terms 30 minutes an hour what are you
guys thinking about in terms of how long
a show should be for our platform if if
someone comes and says you know what I
have a great animated series that that I
think can go for 11 minutes or 10
minutes or we see something that really
only should be nine minutes that's all
it needs to be so for example one of the
shows you're doing is humans it is a
thriller something else you're doing is
covering a live event bonnaroo music
festival so there's a real range of
stuff that you're doing what's the
thought process behind you know the
kinds of shows you you want to be doing
well we're obviously start with the
focus of who who is on xbox who's using
our service and its primary Millennials
it's also gamers at this moment in time
that are both women and then and we are
also looking at why they're on our
platform and how we can kind of
integrate the technology to make their
TV experience much richer and more
engaging so when you talk about bonnaroo
the idea is you
a lot of people would like to attend or
maybe they they don't want to attend but
they certainly want to listen to the
music and avoid going to Tennessee so
what we're hoping to do that while it's
unbelievably well attended I think they
get close to a hundred thousand people
at Bonnaroo you can actually have a
virtual festival in your own living room
by being able to choose the stage you
want to watch two have actual real time
interactions with the talent before and
after they are on stage using skype the
first look we got it what might come out
of xbox entertainment studios was of
course we've got halo the signature game
and Steven Spielberg producing on that
program what's the time frame for that
show well look we're in development on
this project we have not much to say
about this one but I must say that on
the other projects that we are
developing again on certain aspects
we're looking at franchise building and
looking at certain levels of IP that can
really expand the franchise or build a
successful franchise that can live not
only with television but also in games
as well the many flagship games that
have come to represent Xbox these are
these are all fair game in terms of
becoming you know television shows well
I must say and this is was a wonderful
discovery for me when I arrived is that
the rich amount of IP that microsoft
owns whether it's from a game fable or
age of empires or Gears of War or Forza
which is an amazing car you know it's a
racing game or halo I mean these are
things that frankly in an if we weren't
attached the Microsoft everyone would
yearn to have and so this gives it's an
amazing platform to work from I know in
traditional TV there are budgets
sometimes in technology you wonder about
unlimited budgets is there a budget here
sure there's a budget and and you know
what just based on by background if
there weren't I would have won but sure
and we're looking at at producing shows
with with kind of the whole range of
budgets whether it's less expensive all
the way up to a really very high premium
budget level that you would find let's
say of a game of thrones the way you
measure a show success is changing in
the turn
world of television it's the ratings so
that the advertisers can sort of be
pleased in the world of Netflix if they
can grow their subscriber base you would
expect that doing shows like a house of
cards gets a check mark in your world
what is the measure of success I think
there's something like 48 million xbox
live users around the world is it to
grow that number is it to grow the
overall pie people who are using an Xbox
look first and foremost I'd love to
create hits hits that that that the
people who are already on our platform
love people that want to keep that
subscription alive and new people that
can come in I want to be able to use our
content to kind of expand I would say
the Microsoft or xbox fandom and to be
able to really generate real loyalty to
our brand Microsoft has a new CEO satya
nadella is he committed to this to
what's happening here in Los Angeles
very much very much you know he's
committed to he understands that xbox is
a very important consumer facing brand
and he understands it is essential to
the growth of the other aspects of the
microsoft business so I've heard nothing
but very positive support and with the
realization that is going to take some
time to grow the studio Sony with the
PlayStation has said they want to do
originals too and obviously they've got
a big TV business here in Los Angeles is
that a competitive threat to what you're
doing it isn't I mean look we've been
added for a year and a half we've
Microsoft's have dedicated a whole
studio to support this kind of content
development look sony has been in the TV
business for some time the idea that
playstation whose are you know always
focus themselves on gameplay you know
original content is something that
everyone's playing with right now it's
very unclear how committed they are to
that on the playstation so you're
working on a Halo series thrillers
comedies documentaries on sports and I
know you guys have a partnership with
the NFL and I know there's a lot of
sports that are can
zoomed in your own household yes what
should we be thinking about does that
mean that xbox is going to go out and
acquire the rights to live sporting
events outbid the broadcaster's or how
should we think about that so to your
point that we're looking at 48 million
subscribers and we're looking with the
xbox 360 in addition to the Xbox one you
know close to a hundred million consoles
that are connected in the living room
throughout the world Sports is an
essential part of their viewing whether
it's football american or the real
football obviously the NFL is really
important for the US audience you know
formula 1 these are all things that
we're looking very closely and really
feel that with our technology we can
really enhance that experience if you're
an xbox user but you're also using let's
say other Microsoft devices you know I'm
sure some people are going to wonder can
i watch some of these shows on say a
surface tablet or a windows phone what's
the game plan with all that to me it's
it's also engaging through our content
the other devices that we're producing
and the other services that we're
offering so the expectation is is that
service will live on other devices as
well